well airbnb promised to crack down on
renters hosting parties this new year's
but as the holiday gets closer
there are a lot of homeowners who are
worried about unruly get-togethers
especially with cobot cases at the
highest levels we've seen
eight news now reporter madison
kimbrough spoke to some residents about
their concerns for the holiday madison
yeah we did and in this neighborhood
they have their fair share of airbnbs
and short-term house rentals take a look
this new year's eve a lot of people are
staying in but that doesn't mean they're
not partying
the strip's not closed but the clubs are
closed and that's what people would do
on a new year's eve
las vegas is known for its wild
celebrations but with few party options
many are turning to airbnbs and
short-term house rentals for the holiday
weekend
residents of the historic john s park
neighborhood are worried what that means
for them
i think everyone is concerned about
house parties right now in general
because of the regulations because of
the potential for spreading the disease
my biggest concern is people renting out
the houses to turn them into a club
situation charging to have people come
and party at the house lucas has lived
in the neighborhood for more than a
decade
and remembers a time where a bunch of
random people were parked in front of
his home
and there were sometimes 20 25 cars in
the street
so we're talking probably 50 60 people
in that house that's when it becomes a
big concern figgler understands the
temptation to gather at people's homes
but trust the city to get involved
if things get out of hand the city has
been really good
especially since the last round of new
regulations
of setting up a hotline the hotline is
in place if we ever do see anything out
of the ordinary
and we will have that hotline up on our
website if you experience any hot or
excuse me house parties in your
neighborhood that you feel are of high
occupancy
and not following covet protocol
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now